[Musique]
pour mon fils j'ai plus rien à attendre
comme il est décédé or mon objectif
aujourd'hui
depuis trois ans d'ailleurs c'est c'est
ce numéro ouvert que je crie haut et
fort qu'il existe et je ce que je
souhaite c'est faire de la prévention
la prévention mais surtout ce que mon
plus grand souhait aujourd'hui c'est
dans les collèges
dans notre malheur c'est une chance
d'avoir des personnes comme nous qui
veulent témoigner parce que c'est
percutant et beaucoup de parents moi
j'ai beaucoup de parents de collégiens
lycéens qui me disent mais comment ça se
fait que tu viens pas dans les collèges
il faudrait que tu viennes il faudrait
que tu témoignes parce que c'est vrai
que ça percute un et des témoignages
comme le mien c'est vrai qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sont son émule pour qui
quand ils entendent quand ils voyaient
puis qui pose des questions parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup aux questionnements les
parents ont fait de la prévention pour
la drogue pour dans l'alcool pourquoi ne
fait pas pour ça j'ai dit oui justement
moi je me demande pourquoi est-ce qu'on
a peur de l'amalgamé ce qu'on a peur de
la psychose
j'aidais mon but de témoigner c'est
parce que ça mon but de témoigner cette
fête d'apporter des réponses aux parents
aux enfants aux élèves ou voilà c'est
surtout ça c'est une thérapie j'ai
besoin de parler nous au fisc
voilà pour moi parler de lui ça fait
revivre encore et puis puis savoir que
c'est un bon gamin qui s'est fait avoir
quand même quoi c'est surtout ça savoir
qui c'était malgré ce qu'on entend un
son choix c'est vrai nom s'était pas du
tout son choix je pense qu'il avait
envie de partir aider mais quand il est
arrivé là bas je crois qu'il a eu des
grosses surprises